absolutely like a good example is kovid
our our country is literally
falling apart there's
they're talking about bread riots right
i'm not even kidding let me we'll
put up that's interesting are bred riots
coming to america also notice
the ad at the top is a bunch of body
armor huh
are bred riots coming to america you
know what i don't know but maybe but
here
the issue i see is the big problem i
think it's affecting us right now is
that we can't talk
literally no one can talk about say
hydroxychlorquin
yeah and you have dr harvey rish
of yale md phd writing op-ed after op-ed
about how he thinks it is helpful
yeah about how it we can use it to to
end this crisis
you've got articles coming up coming out
about the low death rate
right the deaths going down but the only
thing you're allowed to talk about is
that it's getting worse period
even though most people don't see it you
know
you look at the polling for republicans
they almost exclusively don't care about
it
right at all like the sturgis motorbike
rally they just show up
yep they're doing their thing but when
you look to the left they're screeching
like why won't people wear masks they're
terrified they want to give you oxytocin
to make you more likely to wear your
mask
yeah so what are we supposed to do
you know it's it's interesting i did a
segment on
um on masks because
we had the adolescent gym in new jersey
they actually revoked the business
license
of the city did right yeah it was the
city and it was a democratic council it
was five to one and what what is this
you know if the if the media doesn't
allow conversations like
the the newsweek one and they have to
panic
because they're terrified of this
activist group of people like we're
we're screwed man
yeah like i mean i'm not even kidding
we're talking about 30 to 40 million
evictions
and if anyone steps out of line even the
president
it's just lie after lie after lie in the
media the only thing you'll
do i mean i'll tell you what if i came
out and made a video
where i pushed the most unhinged and
insane far-left conspiracy about
kovid saying it was worse and the end is
coming and it's trump's fault i'd be
fine
yep they wouldn't do anything negative i
i could read one article
talking about hydroxychloroquine and
then they shut it down they ban you
and and there have been youtubers
already banned
it's so weird this article to me because
in it they talk about how desperate
people are getting
and how much they're struggling and how
little money they have and what an issue
it is for them to be
stuck in you know coveted nightmare
covid
purgatory and their final solution is to
say that they
are in need of government help that's
their ultimate
sentence they're like we just need help
from people like we need help from the
government the republicans have to be
willing to give people things and i'm
like why don't we just
reopen the economy why don't we let
people go to work
you're not allowed to say that why is
that i don't know
i don't know and it's and it's it's
tiresome man
it is it is it is increasingly tiresome
it is increasingly
frustrating that you know
the restrictions that are increasingly
put put in place i think things are
getting better i mean we just saw
crowder got
reinstated into the partner program
that's great so hopefully
you know it's not that bad and it's
getting better
but you look at what's going on in new
york and
it feels like sometimes they're trying
their hardest to help trump win by
destroying everything
yeah and you kind of you kind of floated
that theory before that they actually
want trump to win
and i've kind of seen that with the
media where they get this huge bump from
him so to me that
kind of makes sense maybe they want to
keep him in i don't know
but maybe that's it yeah uh
there was an article we had from digiday
talking about how
all these news outlets are starting to
panic what are they going to do
once trump is out of office like their
revenue stream is gone who are they
going to talk about
i mean cable tv for sure i think
everyone except tucker carlson and
hannity
will just evaporate overnight yeah
tucker and hannity had
record uh ratings for cable history
yeah that's weird to me especially
considering
i mean no one even watches cable anymore
but they they do for them i suppose
and so i think if trump were to lose
yeah cnn's gone msnbc whatever all these
channels are just gone
fox news would still be around but their
ratings would be
a lot lower right i wonder what it is
that that causes cable tv to do that
well i understand it's trump
but like why cable tv specifically i
think it must it must just be older
people
an older demographic it's not that's not
true no you don't
it's not it's not what are the stats on
it it's it uh
tucker carlson specifically is getting
like 30 year olds
really yeah 30 year old dudes i did not
know that yep
that's like the coveted demographic it
is yeah he's nailing it
and then you're actually we're actually
seeing the key demo go up for the other
for these other other channels as well
i definitely think covet has pushed
people into a
you know like really politically active
space yeah well it's definitely pushed
them home
and given them more free time it's given
them free time to catch up on the news
and i think
probably more people are following
current events than uh were before
because they have time
they're not at work anymore right
exactly sit around and think yeah
there's no sports
right oh yeah and i'm seeing a lot of
people get active on twitter
and that kind of sucks yeah because it's
like man if only we could
do something else but but yeah it's it's
you know people are getting active on
twitter
i'm seeing people i know from back home
all of a sudden now are tweeting
non-stop turning up oh boy
yeah and i'm like these are people who
don't normally talk about anything
they're being activated
they are being activated i think it's
partly due to
the democrats strategy they need a
massive voter turnout
they do don't they yeah so you know look
i'm not one to push conspiracies but
i gotta say when the governors of these
states are arresting people for opening
their businesses
with no scientific justification i'm
like are you really that dumb
and evil maybe i
don't know but what that would be the
simplest solution wouldn't it they're
dumb and evil yeah they're just dumb
maybe just dumb
i guess we could give them the benefit
of the doubt and just call them kind of
why would i give them the benefit of the
doubt
fair point that's fair i don't know
there's there you know i saw
somebody posted uh earlier that trump
was evil
again another one and i'm just thinking
to myself like
as time goes on they used to have there
used to be arguments that i would hear
about trump and i'd be like
that's a good point you know is it
imperfect a guy
now the only arguments they have are so
unhinged i'm like i don't remember i
don't remember the last time someone
said something about trump that was bad
that actually made a point that made me
consider trump was bad right and that
makes me think you know everything i've
observed that i didn't really like about
trump
i observed for myself i did not need
anyone else to tell me
that trump made a mistake that he called
someone a name that he said the wrong
thing in a press conference
i saw that for myself so when
i mean maybe it's just because the media
is breaking and we're all starting to
pay attention
yeah like maybe you know i know it's
it's true to say
early on in in you know trump's in the
2015 cycle
they were lying about what trump was
saying oh yeah and then we had the
shinzo abe thing so i've known
there's been a lot of lies but there
there's been legit things like
you know the easiest thing to call to is
the rosie o'donnell thing yeah
you know what's crazy is that i i that a
lot of people don't know this
there's that viral video of where trump
is doing the arm thing
you know what i'm talking about where he
like he like shakes and he puts his arm
up or whatever and he's like
and the media ran this narrative that he
was mocking a disabled journal a
disabled journalist
like a certain journalist a specific guy
who has
i'm like was that a setup did like how
did trump
fall like i don't understand because
apparently i've seen i've seen the
videos now
trump does that to make fun of everybody
have you ever seen
i'm gonna ask this seriously and i don't
mean this in any kind of disrespect have
you ever
seen a reporter who's had a
developmental disability like that
before
no i think it might have been a setup
and that's terrible thing to say i mean
i don't know
no no you don't think so no because how
are you gonna
i mean i guess they could trick trump
they knew like trump likes to do this so
that's
but that's that's silly because you
never know when trump's going to act
crazy or whatever true and you know what
that would have required a little bit of
forethought so i will rule that out
completely because i don't think they
have any forethought whatsoever
i've i've never been more conspiratorial
in my life
than this whole year this year yeah
because it's like
things make literally no sense why like
you you i can't remember who tweeted
about this but
um it was like a journalist it was a
prominent journalist that the uh
oh i think there was a guy who was used
to the new york times the sun belt
states never locked down they're doing
fine
south dakota never locked down their gdp
is actually like slightly up
yeah all of these other states are
putting sick people in nursing homes or
did
yeah and they're shutting things down
and for what up apparently for like some
kind of gigantic virtue signal
i really don't know because if you're
putting sick people in nursing homes
what
really are you going for to me that
feels like
nothing but a virtue signal saying we're
doing something and
maybe not even the right at least that
had to be some kind of
i don't know man to me that's like pure
evil because i've worked in hospitals
and nursing homes
that is not a place where you take that
kind of stuff lightly like you put on
ppe for everything that someone else
might get you you really wanted to make
sure that your old people
don't get sick they put people with
kovid
in nursing homes in multiple states yep
and for for what reason did they do this
and now a large portion of those who
died were in nursing homes
yeah and and yeah old people are
naturally immunocompromised at a certain
point especially people in nursing homes
that is
cruel that's not really cruel there's
there's no like conspiracy theory it's
literal it's like
no this happened yeah they they took
people and put them in
in in a place with the most coveted
vulnerable people possible
and that accounted for a lot of the
death like the people who are more
likely to die from covet are older
people
of course yeah so why would they do that
and that's right look i've never been
more conspiratorial
i haven't either it's making me feel a
little weird because i'm not naturally
conspiratorial i tend to
i'm very skeptical i'm like i don't
believe you know i want to see for sure
what's happening but i'm watching them
put
sick people in with old people and i'm
like what is happening
and why i hate it i really like old
people and then you have to speculate
because they can't be that stupid
there's no way
and and i think cuomo's even talked
about it he blames trump for it
he's like oh trump told us to do it or
something like that then why are
all the states not doing it because
they're full of it they're lying
yeah i i i have i i have no answer all i
can tell you is man
it's it just feels intentional
yep and then what about the riots
you know what you know what i was
thinking the other day they could have
released that body cam footage is pretty
much as soon as they had it
keith ellison said no why did keith
ellison say no
he literally said i don't want to
compromise a successful prosecution
really yes that's that's actually what
his reason was
that's amazing and now the body cam
footage has come out from the george
floyd incident and we know
this the initial the narrative they gave
us was not true but
i i even read the report it's it's so
it's so
man i had someone uh criticizing me on
facebook
saying that i wouldn't talk about the
police brutality and i'm like i have and
i
i covered this like every to every
degree
when when the george floyd thing
happened i literally you know went step
by step i remember that yeah
and i read i read one of the reports
that said they pulled him out of the
vehicle for some reason
and then pinned him down and i was like
wow and i was like that's it they pulled
him out again
yeah they could they had him in the
vehicle turns out he kicked his way out
and he said holds me on the ground i'm
claustrophobic and all these things
three times yeah and so i still think it
was a
you know it's unfortunate circumstance
and we want these things to happen
but they held onto that body camera
footage that would have proven all this
and stopped all of it
yeah by the time they let it out the
riots were off and running like there
was
no stopping this and people are writing
for reasons of their own
and it's it's taken on a life of its own
like i don't even know what people are
on about anymore you know what really
bugs me
i keep getting text messages from the
same numbers
for the same candidates but from
different people
like they hand each other the phone and
say just try again that sounds like fun
yeah so uh i got a text message i think
yesterday
and they were like can we count on you
to make a donation to you know this
progressive whatever
and i said straight up i was like
absolutely not because i'm tired of the
riots and i'm tired of the lies
yeah like the riots have been going on
and the media is acting like it's not
happening
what do they say they i understand can i
ask who you're supporting
the only person who has said they will
deal with the riots
and like and who is that and i'm like i
hope you have a nice day
yeah and then today i get a text message
from the same number
it's a different name hi this is jack
yesterday you know yesterday it's like
hi it's mike now it's jack
or your sarah or whatever and we're
hoping you contribute to the campaign of
this person or whatever and i'm like i
told the person the exact same thing
yesterday
i was like you know they raised the
bridges in chicago and shut down
the the loop area they're like shouldn't
people know about what's going on
they sure should i wonder why it is
youtube allows channels like this to
exist
like ours yeah what makes you wonder
like
because we're talking bad about the
narrative and and
and everything they've put forward like
the the the
i don't know is it to feign there's some
kind of objection
to i think so i think i think they have
to pretend that they're mildly objective
i don't think they see any way around
that
because with so many different avenues
of social media there's going to be some
way you can speak up and say something
i think maybe it has to do with like yes
you know they want to make it look like
you have an objective platform yeah
and i think it has a lot to do with if
there is no
you have controlled opposition
essentially not that there's anyone at
youtube telling me what to say
but i do think it's rather interesting
that
certain channels seem to do okay and
certain channels don't and certain
channels get deleted
and i think there's an acceptable
opposition that these companies feel
safe with i think it's mostly business
related
but i wouldn't be surprised if it was
political as well like they're both
interests that companies have
and so it's basically like one of the
things i've talked about before is how
they spin the wheel
so that far left becomes left you know
right wing becomes far right
centrist becomes right wing they want to
shift everything over
and so they're okay with like you know a
liberal like me
doing content that's you know talking
you know against the democrats because
they want an acceptable opposition right
that almost sounds like an art of war
strategy
so if you if you have opposition
do everything in your power to kind of
contain them and control them to a level
that you can
you can actually like keep track of what
they're saying
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you